So why is DNS vulnerable in the first
place? So the fundamental reason is that the resolvers
that issue the DNS query trust the responses that
are received after they send out a query regardless
of where that response comes from. So sometimes these
responses can be forged. When a resolver sends out
a query, it typically generates what's called a race
condition And if the attacker replies before the legitimate
responder, then the resolver is likely to
believe the attacker. DNS responses can also
contain additional DNS information that's unrelated to
the query. The fundamental problem. Is that the
basic DNS protocols have no means for
authenticating responses. This allows an attacker to forge
responses after a resolver sends a query.
A secondary reason that these types of spoofed
replies are possible is that DNS queries
are typically connectionless unlike BGP where routing messages
are transmitted. Over a reliable TCP connection, UDP
queries are sent over a connectionless UDP connection.
Therefore, a resolver does not have a way
of mapping the response that it receives for
a query other than the query ID. Which can be forged by the attacker. Let's look
at how the combination of the lack of authentication and the
connectionless nature of a DNS query allows the possibility of cash poisoning.